In this video we're going to show you how you can integrate Burp Suite Enterprise Edition with
Skim when you're using Okta as your identity provider. Now before we start you'll need to
make sure that you've already created your users and groups within Okta and you'll also
needed to have created the app integration within Okta for Burp and also configured SAML within
Burp to use Okta. If you need any help with this you can view our documentation pages or watch
our videos on our website. Now the first thing we're going to do is create an API token for Skim.
To do this we'll go to Settings, Integrations, scroll down to Skim and click Configure. We'll
need to choose a port for Skim to work with. This can be any free port on your machine. I'm going
to choose 1337. Okta require that any Skim communication takes place over TLS. So we
need to tick Use TLS and then upload our certificate. The requirements for the certificate are the same
as any requirements that we have for certificates elsewhere in Burp. So if you need to help generating
the certificate you can view our documentation pages. Once you've uploaded your certificate it's
important to take note of the base URL format. Now this is https colon forward slash forward slash
the host of your enterprise instance the ports you've chosen at the top forward slash Skim
forward slash v2. Once you've made note of that you can save and generate your API token. Now you
need to make sure that you copy this token and save it somewhere else because you won't see it again.
So I'm going to click Copy Token and then close this dialog. Now if you do forget your token you can
regenerate it at the top but it's important to know that this will disable your old token. I'm just
going to click Regenerate API token here and then Generate New Token and then copy this token somewhere safe.
Once you've done this the next thing to do is to go into Okta and configure the Skim integration.
To do this you'll need to go to the Okta administration page, go down to Applications and then go to
Applications in there. Then you'll need to find the application which you've configured to work with Burp.
Once you're in here you can go to General, Edit and then tick Enable Skim Provisioning.
You'll need to then save this. The page will then refresh and you'll gain a new provisioning
tab at the top. We're going to go there, click Edit and then type in our Skim Connected Base URL.
This follows that format I was talking about before. So it's going to be https colon forward slash forward slash,
the host of your enterprise instance, the skim port which you've selected, so colon that port, forward slash skim, forward slash v2.
For the unique identifier field you'll need to put in a username with a capital M. For supportive provisioning actions we're going to choose push new users, push profile updates and push groups.
And for authentication mode we're going to use HTTP header where the authorization token is the token that we call it.
The token that we call it the user.
And that is how you integrate Burp with Octa and Skim.